[Music]
hello and welcome to this the very first
episode of night city wire a brand new
series from us at CD Projekt RED will
we'll be talking about all things
cyberpunk 2077 for today's episode we'll
be starting with a brand new trailer one
of our developers will be joining us to
help unpack everything you're going to
see we'll have some news an announcement
about a secret collaboration we'll be
taking a look at some brain dansgame
play and welcoming back our developers
just to have a chat about everything
you're going to see but there is one
more thing media all over the world have
been getting hands-on with cyberpunk
2077 and when this episode finishes
you'll be able to go and check out
exactly what they thought so let's get
started it is time to take a look at our
brand new trailer and after that I'll
lead quest designer papal fasco will be
joining us because I've got a feeling
you're gonna have a few questions after
watching this so let's take a look
of this time city of endless opportunity
ready to get your cherry popped
come on see like any other just bigger I
just did another city legends are born
here major weeks
rolling here cuz Dex on the strings
doubt that put to cease and we booze
them but we are they just don't know it
yet but if you got the cojones you know
how to use them you could do damn near
anything unless you catch it ball even
then you go out with the bag right you
know you can make heaps more eighties
motivational speaker
yo mr. V a pleasure so what's the game
Dex
we need to come out in one piece how
about we go over the plan there's this
prototype to a biochip to be precise
jobs the plan
guessing it belongs to a court era
starter
Robbi some heavy-hitters but you can
blackmail me [ __ ]
how is have a war first rule of the
afterlife to cut King baby
it goes without saying we do this on the
hush I deal II nobody not a one
sounds simple enough
gonna be dangerous don't you worry boy
we're bulletproof what the [ __ ] is
happening in there it stopped digging
nice [ __ ] meat you happy now Jackie
oh my god was so [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
six what the [ __ ]
gay miss could be and you who are you
[ __ ] so the trailer contains footage
from the game's prologue only but there
was an awful lot in it so Pavel why
don't you try and help us unpack
everything that we just saw oh yeah I
mean absolutely I can try so would you
have just seen it's only the prologue of
the game so that awesome stuff is only
happening in the first few quests what
the trailer show you who is really our
stage the night CT you know this
gigantic city build of six completely
unique districts surrounded by the
seventh one that we call the badlands as
a player you are meeting
Jackie Jackie's your friend now they
together are trying to reach out for
something that is very precious they
were trying to reach out for this chip
of immortality this gateway to eternal
life Jackie introduces you to fixer
dexter deshaun he's a very important
person in a social ladder of cyberpunk
he is able to provide the player with
various jobs and contracts to be able to
gather money to be able to modify their
bodies push themselves to the limits to
put their hands on a chip but as you can
expect not everything goes as planned
and but to to see it you will have to
play the game there are an awful lot of
really cool things in this trailer and
there's a few that I would just love to
talk about a little bit more for the
people at home so let's start with
talking about a gang called the MOX now
we see a few flashes of them in this
trailer I personally think they're
really cool on one of my favorites but
can you give us a little bit more
information about them oh yes so the box
is one of the gangs that player is going
to interact with throughout the game the
box is the gang that has been formed in
2076
after death of Elizabeth Borden she was
called Lizzy now she was an owner of a
brothel and former sex worker
she was protecting working guys and
girls from harassment from abuse and the
gang is really continuing her mission
and as a player you are going to
interact with that gang meet multiple
different NPCs and craft your own
relationship with them and understand
what they are all about so earlier on
you did mention a seventh district a
place called the badlands now we saw a
few shots of this in the trailer but I'd
love for you to give us a bit more
detail about the district's outside of
the city walls okay so the badlands is
this like dead dried-out space going
around the whole night city and as a
player you'll be able to traverse that
space in your car and motorcycle this is
a space that is inhabited by the nomads
nomads are living in a different
families and they're traveling across
that space in convoys made out of the
cars and motorcycles and as a player
you'll be able to traverse an access a
different type of open-world content
that has been prepared specifically for
you to that get that awesome feel of the
badlands as an area in the trailer we
also saw like a completely metal
creature now he didn't look like he was
from the Maelstrom gang this looked like
something else so this other people at
home who is this giant metal monster
okay so so the big dude that was atom
smasher he has been introduced in a pen
and paper in cyberpunk 2020 by our
senpai Mike one Smith atom smasher is a
fully converted cyborg he is who was
always a loyalist of Arisaka and time
has changed and in 2077 he had to find
his own space in night city but to find
out you have to play the game in this
trailer we do see some flashes of a
ripper doc call Victor vector I think if
people have watched our previous
gameplays they might remember him but
I'd really like for you to give the
people at home some more information
about what Ripper docks are and how
they'll be interacting with them when
they play cyberpunk so report dogs in
our game
they are surgeons they are like a
specific type of a job in the social
ladder of cyberpunk
they are accustomed and specialized in
replacing limps to the metal ones they
can basically update your body enhance
your body change you into this
walking war machine and as a player you
are going to move different kind of
Reaper dogs in the game craft your own
relationship with them some of them are
like important characters for a for a
story to that you will invest Eddie's
that you're gathering to turn your body
into this tool that allows you to
survive on the streets of night see
Pavel thank you so much for joining us I
know you'll be back later in the episode
because you're going to be helping us to
analyze the brain dansgame play but
before that we do have some news to
share earlier in the year we announced
that if you pick up cyberpunk 2077 on
Xbox one you'll be able to play it on
xbox a series X when the console
launches and just in case you missed it
it will be the same for PlayStation
players as well if you pick up cyberpunk
2077 on PlayStation 4 you'll also be
able to play it on playstation 5 when
the console launches and that's not all
there will be a free upgrade for Xbox
series X and Playstation 5 but we'll
have more details on that soon tonight
city before we reveal our first look at
the brain dansgame play and welcome back
our developers for a chat there is just
one more thing we want to announce
something that we've been working on in
secret for a while we are very excited
to announce our partnership with studio
trigger and network to bring you
cyberpunk edge runners a standalone
anime set in the cyberpunk universe
which we've been working on for some
time now edge runners is due to launch
in 2022 but for some more information
let's go to the team in Tokyo
[Music]
hey my name is saya elder I am the Japan
based producer for cyberpunk edge
runners what I do basically on this
project is that I am a fixer to put it
in the words of the cyberpunk universe
we are a game company we are a bunch of
nerds and wherever there are nerds
there's gonna be Ani make sense so it's
was always a dream for us to make on
eBay when we began this project we were
certain that we didn't want to make a
recreation of the game
cyberpunk edge runners is a standalone
story set in the same universe the stage
is still night city but everything else
is totally new new characters new story
I do like to think that it's going to be
a great gateway for newcomers to come
and check cyberpunk game and also the
cyberpunk genre as a whole
right now we're in Nakano which is one
of the biggest anime of mecca's of the
world I'm gonna take you to studio
trigger right now because we have the
wonderful opportunity to talk to the
dream team that will be bringing you
this anime con you Joe Mannino
Watzke this come token or you might say
this character design your turn to
through your snug this gave me no
cyberpunk no the conga has you made a
who'd ever cut your horny Mantzoukas
theta decay do any anime let's go to
support yes there are Spanish mas
congressman so I don't Punk to you ooh
clever dude I know it's caca Coronel
America's on do hey so you don't know
but it's like a ransom state it's good
it to you know he promised me this to do
junetta today how do any image character
design me personally to cut Oregon
psycho knowledge in the 20 car to
shooting Sachi Cikini stick tight to my
ass what I was reading
[Music]
now it's time to show you some gameplay
of brain dance this is a feature that
you'll experience when you play
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance is
essentially a recording of somebody
else's experience it allows you to
relive their sense of sight smell touch
and even hearing all thanks to a special
device after the gameplay I will be
welcoming back Pavel Sasuke
I will also be joined by Patrick Mills
our senior quest designer and all-round
law master who will be helping to answer
your questions and give you some
explanation on how you'll be interacting
with brain dance when you play cyberpunk
2077 so let's take a look
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash get
out and we sell the Biddy to go psycho
freak small studio got it got it and
remember everything on full blast don't
spot us extra for a wicked adrenaline I
okay on you go
down everybody on the graph what I see
you kissing the flooring money now where
I will [ __ ] drop you I swear to God
well yeah yeah now
ah slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well
that was too much felt feel the guy's
pain his dress his hope hope wrapped up
in something else
mmm-hmm probably took a booster just
before you'll be fine got everything set
up let's switch over to editing mode
I'll sever the link to the BD rollers
sensory array you'll be able to look
around 3d will see yours full cam
control and analysis mode so move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with think of it as your own little
sandbox so analysis mode you control
playback can even pause when you feel
the need then you use the editor console
to unpause try it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash get
out and we sell the BD to those psycho
freaks from Studio got it got it
Prima's hell right well that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like give it a try
rewind roll it back to the top good now
try fast-forwarding
plans simple do nothing okay you can
also reset the recording that'll take
you right back to the beginning
now first on the fun this here's why you
came in the first place in analysis mode
you get to view and even scan details of
the enviro recorded by the Beauty roller
focus on the heat the gun this girl gets
from his buddy at the beginning now
scanning
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in snatch the cash okay
right here
excellent let's move on now heads up in
analysis mode you can ferret out
background noise and conversations if
the ruler got close enough this check
records everything every little detail
even the sights and sounds the roller
was never aware of to see the sources of
the recorded sensory signals switch to
the audio layer in the editor go ahead
and try that now okay good now you
should see several sound signatures in
the store choose one and holding on it
like a six case of broseph and a couple
of zappers okay flavors everybody so any
thoughts unbelievable seriously like
what's happening right next to me
it's how BD recording implants work
they pick up everything all the elements
in the background then editor tweets
makes them pop keep playing with the
sound explore it a bit we'll move on
when you get bored
what are you kissing the flooring money
yes sometimes you can analyze extra
layers and the raw stuff the roller is
fiber where picked up like what Ed's got
Karoshi optics that grab infrared
meaning you should be able to grab heat
signatures from her recording huh hello
nice scanning works on peeps to walk up
to the wounded chick try scanning her
alright next thing scroll forward to the
part where our artist gets a med
injection see that they shot him and he
never saw it coming but you will here it
comes
my favorite part of the game see the
blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam must have caught our
shooter you'll see in a sec cam feeds to
the screen behind the clerk roll back to
where the screens and the kids field of
vision then scan it
his own jun by Charlaine probably
planned to all along must've got a nice
slice of cred on the black market for a
beauty like this beady freaks are ready
to pay a premium for real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit yeah suppressive rate too bad most
of the biddies we do here are only good
for flog and relock so brain Downes is a
pretty big part of the cyberpunk
universe it's not just something used
for adult films there is an awful lot to
it and there's two sides
I'd really like you guys to help me
explore first is the law so how this
actually fits into the universe and then
there's the gameplay side so how players
will be interacting with it so Patrick
could you tell us more about the lore of
rain dance
I would love to so in the world of
cyberpunk 2077 brain dance was invented
way back in the early 2000s at UC Santa
Cruz it was developed as a way of
recording a person's experiences and
then playing them back for someone else
as so that they could relive them as
though it was happening to them it was
originally used for things like therapy
and prisoner rehabilitation but by 2077
it's become this global media industry
including things like movies mass mass
entertainment things like that video
games some interactive things and of
course adult fare as well now in our
game we deal a lot with black brain
dances or XP DS as we call them and
there are different types of those but
the one that you saw in the trailer just
there was a flat liner now that's where
the person recording it actually died
you
I'm thrill but a mercenary can also use
them for various things and you'll see
that in the game of course and from the
gameplay perspective we have been
working a lot throughout last year's
trying to figure out the best way how to
use the brain dance in the game as a
mechanics so what we have settled on is
this
Brandon's editor mode as a player you
will be able to run the Brandon's in the
editor mode and see different clues that
have been registered on the peripheral
of given actor now as a player you can
slide on a timeline of the recording
back and forth trying to uncover
different clues and that clues are
actually telling a story in the game so
as a player you will run different
investigations that will lead you to
different mysteries and you will uncover
them actually using the brain dance as a
mechanics in the game
so as Pavel was saying we use brain
dance as a storytelling tool it's not a
collectible it's not something where
you're gonna go in and you're gonna play
it and you're gonna be like I've seen
this before what we use brain dance for
is to give you a keyhole into the life
of the residents of night City and we
can explore things like childhood trauma
religion various philosophical ideas in
a way that you might not otherwise
experience in a story about a mercenary
on the tough streets so we've tried to
talk about some of the aspects that we
think the community will find really
exciting but you know while you're both
here I'd love to know what is it about
cyberpunk that you guys are really
excited for Patrick why don't you start
so one of the things that I'm most
excited about in this game is the
characters and the way they interact
with the world we've got this really
interesting world that stretches all the
way back to the cyberpunk 2020 source
material and all of these events and all
those things but those don't mean
anything unless they connect with
characters and so when we come up with a
character we start with their function
what is this person what do they do in
this story but we don't stop there we go
back and we figure out what was their
childhood like what was their upbringing
like what kind of obstacles did they
face in this harsh reality and did they
overcome them and how did they overcome
them or did they not overcome them and
why
and you can see all of those things in
their environment in their dialogues in
sort of how they operate in the world
and we come up with up for all of our
characters now you look at someone like
Victor vector and you're gonna see
stories about his past in his
environment and in his dialogue you know
we come up with that stuff even if we
don't use it in the game because it
helps inform us as to who these
characters are and for me I would not be
myself if I would not say that I'm the
most excited about our quests like with
our Witcher 3 team with with Patrick and
like everybody that has stayed with us
since The Witcher 3 time we really have
grown so much we have learned so much
and we have used all that experience to
put them into the quests that we have
made and you will not find really a
filler in this game like everything has
a meaning like we put so much effort
into making sure that everything is
rewarding it's interesting it's talking
about characters as patrick said it's
talking about worlds it's talking about
emotions like touching the player and
they're really like a real way and I
just can't wait to find out what you
think Pavel I know you mentioned story
and quests and writing quest and when I
was last in the studio I had a look and
I saw a notebook on your desk and I
would love for you to show everybody
this notebook you asked for it so this
is a my notebook it's as a Southwest
designer the reason is because I dance
salsa and I'm a quest designer so I
wrote started this notebook actually
when we were really starting cyberpunk
at the very beginning I wrote in like a
first note and it says pretty much
something along the lines of it that we
were starting with a prototype and then
you know I kept on the basically noting
things that we've been working on for
like next years I remember once when our
concept artists actually approached me
and they said that they want to take a
look at my notebook I was like what for
actually and they took some pictures and
they told me yeah well you know because
we are looking for a reference material
for a notes of a psychopathic killer so
so yeah well you may find maybe
of my notes again Pavel and Patrick
thank you so much for joining me I'm
pretty lucky because I have read some of
the stories that you and the team have
written for brain dance and I'm pretty
excited for people to discover them but
before we do finish today's episode
there is just one more thing we'd like
to talk about earlier in this episode I
mentioned that media have been getting
hands-on with opening of cyberpunk 2077
and they should be posting their
impressions right about now and if you
missed anything from today's episode
don't worry we'll be uploading
everything to our channels very soon
and finally on behalf of everybody at CD
Projekt RED we just want to say thank
you so much for joining us for this the
very first episode of night city wire
but don't worry we'll be back with
episode 2 in just a few weeks so we
shall see you soon
you
[Music]